un cuerpo abandonado en el bosque y una
fuerte acusación al respecto
imagínense la abominación deben alcanzar
esos demócratas para matar gente y
arrojarla a un territorio vecino esto es
una campaña entiendes es una campaña han
matado a una persona y la han tirado en
nuestro territorio que hay detrás
creo que los investigadores lo
resolverán y evolución del exterior es
virus lukashenko también insistió en la
acusación de que la unión europea
emprendió una guerra híbrida contra
belarrús mientras el bloque acusa a
lukashenko de incentivar a los migrantes
a viajar a belarús y cruzar la frontera
ilegalmente como venganza por las
sanciones impuestas a minsk por los
abusos contra los derechos humanos en
efecto letonia lituania y polonia los
más afectados por la crisis han
desplegado miles de guardias fronterizos
soldados y policías para detener la
migración
quiero asegurarles aquí la plena
solidaridad de la unión europea con
letonia polonia y lituania en estos
tiempos difíciles y este ataque está
poniendo en peligro la vida de civiles
inocentes atraídos a belarús con falsas
promesas
palabras 'no falsas promesas
entretanto eeuu acordó nuevas sanciones
contra belarrús en respuesta a la crisis
migratoria y los diplomáticos de
bruselas sugieren que sean aprobadas e
implementadas a principios de diciembre
la crisis que involucra a miles de
ciudadanos procedentes de irak siria y
afganistán se ha extendido por varios
meses las agencias humanitarias dicen
que hasta el momento 13 han muerto en la
frontera por el frío y la escasez de
agua y comida